vice president's reportedly hiring aides
to help clean up her image and keep her
presidential aspirations alive
after numerous disasters like
afghanistan and the border crisis took a
chunk out of her already infinitesimally
low approval rates i just want that to
know i threw that in there
jessica thank you i just her abysmally
low horrific approval rating so uh jess
b
so listen we're kamala harris i mean joe
biden's been struggling had a tough
couple weeks with his approval rating no
doubt to the point where he's actually
competing with kamala harris but she's
never been particularly proper i'm not a
democrat voter she did not do well in
the country that's a stunner i know but
her one job was the border and she
totally blew it she's m.i.a
it's a much bigger portfolio than after
that in the case of the washington post
piece which went deep into how she's
kind of trying to build her network kind
of continue the work that she did in the
primaries because she did get a lot of
hillary clinton's big supporters like
that was for the female candidates they
were all vying for who's going to get
hillary's tribe and kamala harris got a
lot of the top bundlers there
but now she's handling also the texas
abortion law which is something that
they think will be able to boost her
popularity amongst democrats um but it's
no doubt been a terrible month for both
joe biden and kamala harris and i think
that she's looking ahead to 2024 whether
she's running as vp or if he isn't
running at the top of the ticket there
are going to be people challenging her
and what is she going to say or her
accomplishments for the last four years
that are going to get her out of a huge
primary field because i i assume it
won't be 18 or 21 but it'll be more than
more than one now dana you were in the
white house i mean the reason obama
chose joe biden is because they assumed
he wouldn't run for president they
didn't want that someone that ambitious
i mean that's what at least leaked out
in the media i mean is this is this is
that the best idea to hire someone well
i think he also was looking for someone
who would show some institutional uh
experience somebody like a steady hand
on the tiller that kind of guy and he
was a very good vice president for him
if you're thinking about loyalty to
obama whatever it was yes sir mr
president he got it done this situation
i think is very curious because she was
the first to drop out in the democratic
primary um and now she's hired another
image consultant
to me
she might want to consider asking them
what are the root causes
of
her likability problems and her
political problems
that is actually a little bit more
concerning you can't blame the
communicators for everything they are
the communicators are not at fault at
all this the other thing that's very
strange to me is that
she's not negotiating this 3.5 trillion
right she was she was in the senate why
isn't she there talking to all of her
former colleagues trying to get this
done like that that major job they
didn't give to her yeah joey listen she
was most popular when she was in the
senate and she was a bulldog against
every body they put up on
to be looked at if she wants an image
makeover she should do what a vice
president does they should let her be
the bulldog for the administration i
mean you know friendly uncle joe was
kind of the thing before we all realized
how absent-minded he is she's absent
bring her back in and let her just
attack attack attack but unfortunately
jinsaki and president biden does a
pretty good job with that you know when
the president stands up there and says
we're going to make them pay you don't
think he means a bunch of kids and some
aid workers in afghanistan right and so
they let her go be the bulldog katie
very few people know the border as well
as you do i mean you've been around a
border state your whole life she blew it
i mean she totally and they made her the
czar of the border i don't think she had
ever any intention of actually solving
that problem first of all but i would
say to
address dana's question of what is the
root cause of her
unlikability the the vice president's
problems are created by the vice
president i mean it's very difficult to
hire an image consultant to change
things when you have a background of
having no real principles or policy
positions that you stand on and if you
look at the primary a perfect example of
this was when bernie sanders did a cnn
town hall and he was asked do you think
that felons should be able to vote from
prison including the boston bomber and
he said yes equal harris came out after
that and was asked the same question and
she just followed his lead which got her
into a whole bunch of trouble and so i
don't think that no matter who you hire
in terms of an image consultant based on
the fact that she has no real principles
she's not going to improve hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else